hey everybody welcome to live coding
with Jesse I'm Jesse and I'm so sorry
that I'm late getting started I'm five
minutes late I haven't been this late
and I can't even remember how long so
really really sorry it was just crazy I
had I don't know like less than ten
minutes before was supposed to start
somebody called and I had to go meet
them and when I was on my way back I my
boss came into my office and so anyway
so I can go all day without anyone
talking to me at work and then for
whatever reason in the last ten minutes
I had two people have to talk to me so
oh wow that happens so hopefully it
didn't annoy you you all too much but
today we're gonna work on a different
component so we need I don't know if you
all remember we had a component that was
a page for all the faculty profiles and
I'll show you in a second what
everything looks like
and before we were pulling in all this
markup that we had gotten from the old
database just a bunch of HTML formatted
like as is and we did our best with some
regular expressions to change some of
the markup and with CSS to make it look
good but we had said we're just going to
do this kind of hacky stuff because we
don't have time to go back through each
one of these pieces of content and
actually change the mark-up well now
that I have some student workers that
are just flying through every task that
I give them which is awesome I decided
like alright well now I do have you know
people that can do this so I'm gonna
have them do this so I went through and
I made custom fields for all the
different pieces so like the title the
person's name their title their phone
number
email they're like a PDF upload for
their curriculum vitae so we have all
these pieces broken out now so when you
try to pull in that data it doesn't look
right anymore so we need to grab those
pieces individually and display them you
know as we want so it's not going to
look completely different from what we
had before but it's definitely going to
be nicer so that's what we're going to
work on today
and I think we got a good shot of
getting it done I'd like to finish up
before definitely before 1 because 1
p.m. we have that Alexa skills
livestream starting so I got I don't
want to stream during that in case I'm
sure some of you all may want to watch
that so I'm gonna try to end before then
ok just gonna check the chat and say
what's up before we get to the code all
right Stephen says thanks for messaging
me back I love to think about oh you
know what no problem
yeah no problem Stephen if you all
didn't see at the end the last the last
dream from yesterday I showed off a
bunch of Stephens websites that he's
been working on and they're awesome
really awesome so if you get a chance
check out the last I don't know 10
minutes or so of yesterday stream and
you check out you see some I think
really good examples of websites for
those looks like some hotels and
apartments and things like that all
right let's see all right so we got a
question about laptops for beginners I'm
gonna answer questions after we do our
first coding session so just hang in
there and and I'll talk about that I see
in the chat some some others are giving
you some good answers there as well so
if you want to hear what I have to think
I'll tell you later on in the screen but
I may not have better advice than the
other people in the stream
all right let me show the code there we
go all right I just want to start out by
thanking Chris Brown for this pull
request so in our documentation we just
said to run npm dev and for some reason
i thought with the newer versions of npm
you could just do npm dev and you could
leave out the run but maybe you can
maybe I was mistaken I often use yarn
and to tell you the truth when I do use
MTM I always include the run just out of
habit so I'm not sure either way it's
good that we change this to say NPM run
dev in case somebody's running an older
version of of NPM it'll still work for
them so thank you for that I went ahead
and merge that in and anyone else is
interested in submitting pull requests
if you see something that's messed up in
one of the repositories we have a lot
you can check them you know check them
all out anything in this
FUS - marcom you know feel free to go in
here and check them out and you can open
an issue if you just want to point out
something that's wrong or you could
actually you know send the submit a pull
request and you know have a good chance
of getting it pulled in you know it'll
be something nice for your you get a
portfolio if you're interested also I do
have my own github profile for some of
my personal projects so feel free to
browse through there a lot of my stuff's
also you know open source and free for
anybody to use so sorry I got distracted
by the live chat uh-huh so anyway just
putting that out there that you know
there's a lot more here and on my
portfolio that that don't make it on on
the streams that we've been doing lately
so we have like electron apps react
native stuff going on so a lot more
stuff all right
it's let's go over yeah well let's just
say we'll navigate here to the faculty
so we have our education faculty right
and we will need we're actually going to
need to change this as well now that we
have the data displayed in a different
way but right now let's go let's go to
dr. Susan poyo
I know Susan and her family and she's
awesome so we're gonna go I'm gonna go
here I actually helped maintain the
website for her husband her husband's
website so cool so what we have here
actually I think I just figured out
another tasks that I could give to the
the student workers might not be a bad
idea to get rid of these details
sections so we'll see once they get
through what I gave him earlier today
then I'll give them that one but for now
you can see it's missing a lot we used
to have a photo here and some
information and a link to a PDF all gone
but if we check out in WordPress let's
go back to WordPress and let's find this
same this is good the same professor
look we can see that we have all these
fields so we do we have an image now
let's under the featured image oops I
forgot to start my timer let's start
that off so we have a display name so
this is I guess small distinction but
kind of important when the title of the
post has the last name first which is
good I think for sorting things by
alphabetical order and trying to find it
that'll make it easier but the display
name we wanted to
be nicer right and it's always nicer to
have your name in the right order so we
have this display name now and this
allows for some customization if a
certain professor prefers to have maybe
like all their degrees or titles or
something afterwards then that's
changeable and it won't really affect
you know the official name or the slug
because that's separate then I was
displayed we have a feel for job title
phone email and then we can upload that
CV we also have this search field so
this is gonna help us out with our our
search feature that we haven't quite
finished yet one of the biggest problems
that we hadn't fully solved was how do
we know what page these pieces of
content are going to because we have a
lot of pieces of content and WordPress
all these custom post types that don't
necessarily equate to a single page on
the site and not only that but since we
have that that router function in our
server
jas file it's not always clear what the
URL should be just from getting the data
from the post so the solution at least
the solution that I came up with was
every single post of all the custom post
types is going to have this this field
right so this search field and in that
search field we'll put in what the URL
to the actual page is supposed to be so
then when this piece of content comes up
in a search and you click to go to the
full page it will take you to this page
and so and that's also going to help for
pieces of content that may not actually
have their own page so those sample
courses that we were working with
yesterday those won't exist on their own
pages right the the course schedules
those will always exist mainly on a
program page
it could potentially exist elsewhere but
primarily what we'll want to do with
those is put the link to that that
program page that major or graduate
program or associate's degree something
like that it'll link to there so this is
going to make finishing up that search
feature so much easier I mean that was
that was the main issue that was left
for us to solve there's still some other
things that need to happen before that's
ready to go but those are all things
that I'm really confident that that we
can solve all right so the rest of it
you can see is it's just whatever was
left over all the content is still in
this large content editor spot and it
looks like it's still a bit of a mess so
I'll probably need to do a little video
of me going through one of these and
cleaning it up and then give that to my
student workers so that they can watch
the video learn how I want it done and
then go through all the content and
remove a lot of this junk so you know
all the details tags all these you know
spaces right between there so we're
gonna assume we're not gonna mess with
this stuff and styling this because
we're gonna assume it's going to be
cleaned up probably get cleaned up today
or by tomorrow morning so all we're
going to worry about today is getting
the stuff in here and this image
displayed on the page properly and if we
have time we'll go back through as well
to that faculty list where we display
the names of all the faculty of a
particular department and we'll make
sure that the correct info displays
there as well all right enough talk
let's code
so let me first things first let's pull
in that the latest updates get Poole I
recommend starting your day out or any
time you open a new project throughout
the day with a get Poole just to make
sure that you have the latest changes if
you're working off of a fork update your
fork from whatever the original repo is
that way it could be a mess if you start
working and then later on find out there
were updates then you're gonna have to
fix merge conflicts and depending on how
many conflicts you have that could just
take up your whole day and that happened
to me last night with the the react
native app that I'm working on and it
was kind of disappointing that I didn't
get very much done because I had to work
through all these merge conflicts okay
major we're not gonna be working with
that we need to work with faculty yep so
faculty j/s is what we're gonna work
with and if we have time we'll we'll
also work with faculty list
j/s alright great so you can see right
now not really a lot going on we just
pulled things in as is but we can now
get rid of a lot of this stuff so I'm
going to leave for now this because it's
possible that there are some images
within the the body content of some of
these profiles I haven't seen it but
it's possible so let's leave that in for
now we can take out the whole thing with
our CV and then for now the details page
let's see
the details of it looks like we still
should be taking this out to be honest
with you that's that's kind of weird
let's double check that so we do have oh
you know what because we're doing a case
sensitive I believe if we change this
the case insensitive it'll actually
change this so it'll just look nicer for
now like I said I'm gonna have that that
fixed but this should work so if we add
that I it'll make a case insensitive
[Music]
great and then in terms of you know this
piece here that's that's totally fine
what we need to do is add in a few
things we can also remove this regular
expression to see if we can get rid of
anything else I don't think so okay
let's take a look in graphical what data
we're gonna get and how we can when get
get to it so let's see instead of menus
we're gonna go to faculty let's see if
this will be enough to get us what we
need
great you don't need a link right now ID
we don't really need the ID either do we
let's copy in what we're getting already
so we should have a query
as was their queries
where am I I'm missing these where is it
data no lib there we go in the live
photo okay so here's our queries so we
can go to faculty Louise in fact which
which queries in here profile
okay so we're using the profile query
yeah so let's grab all of this just to
get a realistic picture of what data
we're bringing in
there we go all right so this will show
us what we're actually getting and this
is it and let me you know let me get rid
of content because it's just taking up a
lot of space for me to get rid of
content and then now we're going to add
in which is the field names B I might be
able to just check here actually let's
check faculty and then we can get a list
and faculty
as is node there we go now we're at the
right place alright cool so we have our
CV field so we'll definitely need that
we need our CV field we need our eye
we're gonna have subfields for this one
so without you all right let's try value
to this value okay back its and this so
for people who aren't familiar with
graph QL this is just a tool graph
graphical is just a tool to search
through your graph QL content so you
just put in your end point up here and
then you can actually just kind of step
through your they call your schema so
that's what we're stepping through to
figure out what the what all our options
are and it's a lot faster to do it in
here than to try to put it in save it
like in our code
save it refresh everything maybe it's an
error maybe it's not so this is a lot
faster so once we get the data we want
showing up here we can just copy and
paste that into our project and we are
gonna be pretty sure that it's gonna
work okay so we had that let me go up
again display name there we go
so one display name and do all of these
I bet all of these need value okay kind
of annoying to have to do value for all
of them but it's
it's not like we have to type it in
anymore we type it in once we have it
we'll copy and paste and we're done
nikki says graphical love that
autocomplete it rocks yeah for sure
it's so useful so you see the odd the
autocomplete actually finding the fields
in the schema that work so if I start to
type something and I don't see anything
come up to autocomplete I know that it's
the wrong thing and it's not gonna work
all right so where do we just hit
display name email so that email field
and then featured image so we're
actually going to be using the featured
image now and I'm definitely gonna have
to go in let me throw a job title just
what before I forget so you I think
that's all we need so for the featured
image it's going to media item
all right there's a lot here is source
URL
we could do sushiro I was hoping that we
could find some of the how they they
break in WordPress will automatically
breaking image down into multiple sizes
so it's hoping we could take advantage
of that I'm not seeing anything like
that here
okay so I'm guessing either source URL
or URI is gonna be what we need so let's
throw them both in here and see what we
get all right okay so each one of these
is gonna represent a faculty member so
here we have dr. Daniel Kempton who's
the Dean here okay so here's that
featured image the source URL okay so
the source URL is definitely what we
want the URI is not helpful to us so
let's get rid of that URI I definitely
want to try to put in
let's try this details
I'm gonna try media details okay and we
have subfields here to see what that'll
give us sizes yes
all right let's let's do that media
details sizes and oh we have more so
let's decide this might be what we need
media sizes yeah let's go with source
URL for our sizes this might be exactly
what we were looking for okay so alright
check this out so here's our source URL
let me make this bigger so for y'all can
see so our source URL for our featured
image is going to be the full size image
as is like as it was uploaded so that's
almost always gonna be not what we want
because it's going to be too big but
then when you now this setting can be
adjusted in WordPress right but usually
by default depending on your theme it's
gonna be it's gonna soon as you upload
an image to WordPress it's going to take
that image and break it down into
multiple sizes so in this particular
case this image has been broken down
into three sizes so this is like your
thumbnail like your small thumbnail 100
by 100 a little bit larger thumbnail 150
by 150 now of course this also involves
some cropping right because the original
image is probably not square I don't
remember what it is actually but your
thumbnails always going to involve some
cropping and then we have this this
other sources I'm assuming smaller than
the original image 300 by 293 so
depending on the original image you may
have even more sizes so it could be that
the original image here is just not that
big so it only gave us three sizes but
if you happen to have
of a really large image you may get a
bunch of sizes now what we can do here
is let's see reference size name let's
let's throw name in here as well because
right now this doesn't really help us if
we wanted to use that right how do we
know which one is the best size so I'm
hoping that name will give us some
insight so we had a name in here there
we go
so it says thumbnail medium and then
this one is the 2017 thumbnail avatar so
this is that theme specific so WordPress
themes can do a lot and in particular
this 2017 theme that is the theme that
we currently have activated we don't
really need it so we may end up
deactivating it at some point but for
whatever reason the 2017 theme needed
100 by 100 images so it's adding in
another automatic cropping resizing
point for these images right so like I
said this source file is probably not
that big so it only gave us medium but
potentially we could have lots of
different ones a small medium large I'm
not sure if there's one above that but
I've seen a lot more anyway I said these
are customizable so we may end up going
in at some point in making our own
custom image sizes we don't really have
a use for it right now but I can see
that happening in the future but anyway
this is perfect this is exactly what we
need and what this will allow us to do
then is look for our image sizes if we
have an image size that would work
better let's say like let's say we want
medium we'll use medium and then
[Music]
probably end up using media queries for
this see how this will work
hmm yeah we'll see how this goes this is
going to be interesting because normally
I would use media queries for this no no
no what am I thinking resource set for
this source set why am I thinking media
queries okay I just saw a question here
it's a good question
Michael crow says did these new
categories come automatically from
WordPress or is it something the student
workers did so all the student workers
did was upload a featured image the
breaking it down into these different
sizes that happen automatically from
WordPress okay so I can't I think there
are some automatic sizes that happen
with WordPress but then they're usually
some that are custom that come with your
theme and then you can customize it even
further if you want usually there's it's
not there's nothing in the UI of the
admin panel that lets you do that unless
you get a plug-in so you it does involve
some some PHP alright but this is
awesome I think this is everything we
need so I mean we'll find out if it's
not everything when we need but for now
I'm going to copy this and add it here
so right after our content
what's wrong with this here unexpected
tag character all right so it's just a
formatting thing I think we're fine
all right cool so now that we have this
let's test it out and try to grab one of
these pieces of data well you know what
I didn't check that value for the CV fit
ok cool that does work I just wanted to
make sure that this value is giving us a
URL and it is so that's awesome
and notice what are you are oh is it's
not pointing us to our WordPress site
you know that's that's a WP dot
Franciscan University this URL is
pointing us to our Google storage bucket
right because we set that up I think we
set that up on on the stream but anyway
we set it up so that anything we upload
the WordPress goes automatically to
Google storage and it is served from
there so nothing stays on our currently
our digitalocean droplet that houses
that WordPress installation and we don't
have a database on that droplet either
so I may keep our WordPress installation
on that droplet because right at this
point it's so lightweight it may work
we'll see the other option that I've
thought about is hosting it with next
michael says my beautiful query
yeah the query is quite a mess now right
it's just yeah we could work with query
fragments if we wanted to to make it
look a little bit cleaner but I'm okay
with this for now one thing we may end
up doing though is like this featured
image this is a really good candidate to
be a fragment because we're probably
going to reuse this for other queries so
at some point we'll probably do that if
in graph QL a query fragment is
basically like pulling out a piece of a
query making it a variable and then all
we'd have to do is just pop that
variable in instead of having all of
this okay all right my timer is up for
that pump into our session so let's take
a short break I've known a lot of
explanations so we're not moving that
fast
for those of you who are pretty advanced
apologies for that but I don't really I
don't want to lose the beginners and if
you're a beginner and you're kind of
lost here feel free to ask any questions
you know I'm doing my best to try to
explain but it's stuff I'm probably
missing a lot of things
it's alright so first question way from
the very beginning of the stream in the
first minute here is kim kim chunsik
what laptop do you suggest for a
beginner it kind of depends on your
budget
so I really like my macbook pro I think
it's a 2015 it was the last model that
had the the full HDMI port so that was
important for me because I didn't want
to buy adapters for four HDMI stuff I
really liked it
I've heard that people aren't as happy
with the newer models of the MacBook Pro
so I don't know but I don't have
personal experience with it my wife has
a regular MacBook and that's fine for
her she does JavaScript Ruby and like
blockchain development stuff on it so
that works it does kind of defense you
on what you're trying to run hmm sorry
for the on so I think you're good with
with those options but they can be
pricey there's so many different options
with with pcs I mean I don't even know
where to begin to give you an advice for
that if you want to go the less
expensive route you could try getting a
Chromebook and then setting up a cloud
development environment like through
something like like cloud 9 and then
you'd have a really cheap operating
system that doesn't get it doesn't get
bugs or you know malware or anything
like that and you'd be able to log into
your dev environment from anywhere I
mean there are advantages to but so if
you're looking to spend the least amount
of money to get into it I would go with
the Chromebook and then you can always
invest later on like I didn't get my
MacBook Pro so I picked up a client and
the cost of the MacBook Pro was only
like 10% of what I was making on that
project so I thought alright fine like
this is gonna help me out with my with
this project so I'm gonna go for it so
if you're just starting out you don't
have any high bank lines yet may not
want to go straight for the MacBook Pro
unless you have a lot of money lying
around that's my advice
Stephen says if you don't want to spend
a ton of money you could go with a
MacBook Air okay I forgot about the air
so the MacBook Air is is less expensive
but but still more expensive than you're
gonna pay for a Chromebook for most
Chromebooks
Sobhan says more RAM and a solid-state
drive is good yeah that's true if you're
going to go like the PC route or Linux
and like really customize and like pick
exactly what you want
make sure the solace a drive is is
really nice to have and more RAM is
always better than less RAM
Benny says can someone give me an
explicit description of what component
did update does also I think I had a
condition when I set that it kept
running repeatedly all right you know
what there's some of those life cycle
methods that that they're kind of
getting rid of
I want his component did update one of
those I don't think component that
update did is is one of the the old ones
I think he's still use it I mean like it
says and from what I remember without
looking it up I'd probably look it up
myself if I had that question decided to
explain it so I'm just saying I don't
it's not fresh in my mind but component
did update goes off whatever you put in
there will run after the component
updates so something changes in state
the rerender happens right if component
needs updated it updates and then that
that runs I mean that I don't know if
that's an official sounding explanation
there but I mean I would I would
probably look it up in the react
documentation they do a good job of
explaining usually what things mean okay
so I'm gonna go back and do another
Pomodoro session after this session I'll
answer all the questions that are left
so we're just going to do one more
session today so that you all if you
want to have a chance to catch that that
next stream about Alexis skills okay so
we have our data we have what we need
let's make sure that we can actually get
that data and display it on the page
let's see I guess we can get that
display name field
yeah all right so let's look at what we
already have because we were already in
make sure I save that in faculty ojs
we're already bringing that data in so
you don't have to go through that
process
what about reusing the Apollo query
component and we pass it a query prop
tell it what query we want to use and
then we pass it the data in this case
it's the type that we're pulling from
from the URL it goes through our routing
function and serve ajs and it sends it
here so down here currently all we're
getting is content and we so up here we
have data this probe type dot edges 0
right so that's how we've gotten the
data that we need and the sea-doos time
why do we have result of hearing what
are we using it for okay
we're using it up here
that's we
faculty okay I see why we're doing it
like that so we're this is more like a
universal code so we're not explicitly
saying faculty here we're using the type
so potentially this component could be
reused for other stuff it's about to get
really specific so probably won't be
able to anymore but let's go our content
note content so one is zero and we
should be able to dot no doubt content
so let's make
I'd say faculty
equals trying to avoid having to type
all this stuff in alright so now let's
add in a div and let's do an h1 and say
what do we have faculty dot I camera we
call it in a display name field
duh value
all right so if I've done this right
this should tell us this should give us
that that value of the display name
field and what did I do
I forgot my closing div okay
all right let's check it out yeah here
we are
dr. Susan poyo cool so now we know we
can get the data pull it in so now it's
just the time to build this component
out and we'll build it out we'll style
it a bit and hopefully it looks nice and
you can see after I've added that that I
in our regular expression to make a case
insensitive it has now changed how this
looks still looks pretty terrible but at
least we can see the content now so I'm
definitely gonna have my student workers
clean up this this markup manually it'll
free up time for us to build out more
components and things if we don't have
to mess with trying to work around this
this kind of really terrible markup all
right so for right now let's just get
the date on the page and then we'll sell
it so let's try this this image next
this one's gonna be fun I don't well
let's see if material UI has anything to
do with images do they not they have an
image avatar
so do they not have an image yeah this
is not what we need okay that's fun just
wanted to double-check to see if they
had something built out for for images
so we're just going to use source set
and it's been a while since I've I've
actually typed out source set you know
from scratch and not just copy and
pasting so let's check out the the mdn
article about this all right so we're
gonna skip over the wire responsive
images we already know we want it so
let's let's check this out here we go
so here's sort of said if you're not
familiar with it it's really cool so you
you put in like it looks like a normal
image tag at first right it starts out
the same but then we instead of just our
source and then you know our older
whatever we put in here we have more
properties more attributes so we have
the source set and in the source set we
give it some more file names or URLs you
know paths to our images so each one of
these corresponds to a different size
image and then we'd say what what with
this should correspond to we have our
sizes which these are like media queries
right they look like media queries
okay so
this uses W unit not pixel as you might
expect the same as real size okay cool
if you want I'm gonna paste this in the
description if you want to read more
about this it's it's super useful so you
can check that out if you want I'm just
kind of skimming through this just to
give me a refresher so I make sure I use
the right syntax basically the only
thing I'm taking from here is make sure
that these are the the actual image
widths and then the width of a slot I
should say okay and then this number is
the screen width but this number is the
the width that the image will actually
need to take up and I thought you could
okay so you can do if you can port width
so that's good to know because I don't
always have set a certain number of
pixels it's usually like percentage of
the page so we can use viewport width we
can't use the percent symbol but we can
use viewport width which represents you
know it's a number between 0 and 100
right so that represents the same thing
as percentage with you know basically so
we're gonna you probably use that
instead of pixels here but yeah this is
so if you've never seen this in action
hopefully I can get it working and it
it's so cool it's just super useful last
thing I want to check is I guess it's it
okay all right cool so the nice thing is
there's a fallback and we notice we
still have this source so on older
browsers I'm not usually worried about
older browsers but it's nice to know on
older browsers that we'll just ignore
this stuff and just load this all right
so by default here they're loading the
largest version of the image so and I
guess that's that makes sense and then
that way it'll be able to cover it'll
still look good no matter what right
it'll take a little bit longer to load
but it'll it'll look good since it's the
largest image all right let's just copy
and paste this whole thing and edit it
as as needed
okay here's the tricky part we're not
always going to have our images right so
[Music]
if we have actually what is this john
saying react image we'll also take
another component to do lazy loading
along with using source set built-in all
right this is worth checking out because
lazy loading is it's actually on our
issues list and github right now so
maybe we can just add it in right now
it's importing it's just importing image
from react image all right let's look it
up quick let me see how much time I have
all right you know what let's save lazy
loading for another stream I I agree and
I think lazy loading is a good idea but
I don't think there's any way that I can
do that and get the rest of these in so
yeah let's let's just wait for this so
it will do in first things first let's
just replace some of these these image
files
let's look up our schema again so we
know how to get there so what is this
featured image media details so featured
image source URL is going to be our
default and we're going to need to
change these up to use
that's weird why is it illness
oh okay I know why someone that kasundi
China uses template literals it's
straight that in HTML and that's not
working we need to go to JavaScript land
for template literals to work and down
here I don't actually need a template
literal all right so here's what we need
faculty featured image right featured
image source URL right okay
and for this one we're gonna say and use
our template literal syntax here to put
in faculty featured feature image which
is it featured yeah Edie featured image
source URL
okay so what what this is going to do
then is anything we put if you're not
familiar with template literals we use
this backtick instead of normal quotes
and then we can put a dollar sign curly
bracket and then anything in between
this opening and closing curly bracket
is not JavaScript and so it allows us to
do cool things within strings without
having to concatenate a lot of stuff
together
okay all right let's see yeah let's put
in the B's copy and paste this really
quick
[Music]
and uh I see factory features for sure
so instead of sushi are we want to go to
this media details sizes give me details
sizes now probably gonna want to take
these out and make them variables at
some point cuz this is going to get
crazy in a second
sizes dot filter and within our felt
here we're going to say image dot name
oops I with this image dot name equals
thumbnail and the for this one we're
gonna say image dot name equals medium
there you go
okay and then for our widths we can
actually go in here and say along with
our name we're gonna say oops that's not
exactly what I want
turn image name equals thumbnail and
then if we do have the image name equals
thumbnail then we want to return image
source URL is that gonna work no it's
not wrong I help me out filter should
automatically then return anything
all right don't need to add a map onto
here then is that my problem
so filters gonna return anything that
fits that so I need to put dot map and
then map is gonna be image and will
return
source URL expected to
michael says you really need to see how
the images look on each screen with
before doing this yeah yeah I know I
just want to get it in here first we'll
get some images in just to see what's
going on and then we'll adjust it but
what did I just do here that mess this
up alright our filter exercises filter
map image why can I not do that
I'm pretty sure I have some some syntax
error going on here but I'm not I don't
know what's happening is it mad because
I'm trying to do all this inside of a
template literal yeah I mean this is a
bit much let's just let's take this out
do Const thumbnail equals
are we still getting this
oops you're right I put equals equals
haha thank you
actually that's this is a case we're
using this font actually was not helpful
so Johnson I think Jesse likes to see
how many lines of code he can get into
one file before you break CVS code huh
yeah what I'm just doing things I
definitely throw in like everything but
this is this is going to end up being
much cleaner so I think it's fine that
we we pulled this out and so now we can
do the same thing for the next one and
call this medium and go for the medium
medium size here and then we can't get
rid of all this great and you put it in
with let's see if we can get it with
here and what value we get I'm hoping
it's just a number yes all right just a
number so this will tell us how Y the
images so then here where we're supposed
to say how Y the images we can just pop
in that that value for width so yeah
we're gonna want to
it's gonna end up getting a little bit
of complicated set of Swiss y'all you go
image with and something down here we
can say
and they're worth
this is so crazy
medium with alright excellent for our
source URL we can also do this let's see
I believe me with
yep Edie details with wow this is 400
wit so it's not a really big image so we
can go in here and say image with equals
and this is going to be faculty featured
image media details this want to be a
lot easier with okay wonderful
oops
image with
okay I just want to see this on the page
no syntax error no closing tag for the
image all right I noticed that at first
and then went through a lot of stuff no
image is not defined whereas it image
not define where am i using image
Oh
Oh
you know I just thought - I hope that
Susan foyers profile actually does have
a medium size and a thumbnail size yeah
it works
all right cool it worked and we should
be able to get different images now
maybe maybe maybe it's just falling back
to the source let's see what we have oh
I know what happened we actually need to
put all of this stuff beforehand I was
gonna make it just just a little bit
more complicated okay so here's the
problem it'll be easier to see over here
so for the source URL we're getting the
full URL so that's why that's still
working but for these ones and the
source URL for our smaller sizes we're
not getting the full URL not only that
but we're not really getting enough to
do this right so this part here is going
to be different so it's not like we can
just have this as a constant so this is
gonna be so tricky alright let's check
out sizes again you see what we have to
work with file all right let's see what
file gives us
yeah same thing with us they have name
with high need the full URL
how do we get the flu your own okay we
could do a regular expression they gave
us everything before the last slash
could we could we not can you do that
and then that's going to be our URL that
we use and we will prepend that on here
oh good idea Nikki says see if featured
image that you query for base URL or
something
alright cool let's go back here
okay yeah we don't have that so I think
probably our best bet would be regular
expression or something that would give
us just what we need up to here and then
we could use that down here and add that
in right before our thumbnail file name
okay my timer went up and yeah we have
about 15 minutes before the other stream
starts so I'm gonna go back to the chat
answer some questions so it definitely
didn't get it finished this source this
using these the source set on this image
tag definitely took up a lot more time
than I had hoped
so we didn't get all the fields in but
we definitely got through the most
difficult of all the fields the rest are
just texts one of them is a download but
we just need one URL for that and not
all these multiple things going on here
so that's what we do we just go down
through and add in this data and then
style it so what I'm thinking for Styles
is on mobile it's going to be you know
dr. Susan Boyle probably the image after
and then it'll have the title phone
number email and then a link to download
the curriculum vitae the only change I
might make is if I'm gonna have the
title at the top maybe I'll have her I'm
gonna have her name at the top I may
have her her title right beneath it I
mean the other potential thing is you
know what if we had the MA
first I don't know I'd love to see how
it looks but that's my idea on a larger
screen I'd like to have the image here
and then all the information you know
right on the side or flipped around I
guess it doesn't really matter we could
have the image aligned either side but
otherwise it'll it'll be side by side so
they'll be columns so let me know what
you think about those I guess the layout
options in the chat and now I'm going to
go back to the live chat and I need to
find where I where I left off how do not
remember oh cool I found it
okay Michael creoles asking about how
Chrome Auto formats JSON says Firefox
dev doesn't automatically describe have
an extension it does all right Nicki
says JSON for matter is the Chrome
extension that does that is that what
I'm using yeah JSON for matter that's
what I use so that's how we did this so
this is JSON normally you it would just
be all together and nearly impossible to
read this makes it look pretty
Stephen says gotta miss the stream have
a creative meeting for the next hour I
will come back and see if you're still
on later
oh well good luck with with your meeting
and thanks for being here for for as
long as you could
Oh Michael would mentioned using an ID
for the key in the map yeah you know
what I probably won't need to use in my
using map anyway no actually I don't
think I will need it I I mean I'm
assuming you're talking about this maybe
you talk about something else but since
it's not actually HTML which that's
coming out I don't think I'll need it
it's just being safe to a variable just
as a string
that's so our horn says hey hey how's it
going thanks for joining us Harshit says
hi hey hard [ __ ] how's it going hard
[ __ ] I did go ahead and I cancelled that
site account we were using for
JavaScript AF so I think we have like 20
at least 20 more days of it if we need
to do anything with it as the accounts
not completely canceled it just drop
down to the free the free tier instead
of the whatever tier we were on
John says what happens if one or more of
those endpoints does not have an image
URL this graph q I'll return an error or
fail alright that's that's actually
interesting what happens if we try to
get data that it isn't there hmm I'm
gonna have to look into that I will
I would hope it would just return the
rest of the data but to tell you the
truth I've I don't remember what happens
it's hard to believe that I haven't had
that situation come up yet but that's a
really good question and definitely need
to test that out
okay michael says i think you get a no
value yeah oh I should say that had to
go for dinner time see how harsh it
actually I'm super hungry right now I
could go for something a it's lunchtime
right now so for me
Harshit recommends using react image as
well
gia says I'm here I'm new here and I
want to ask is this project for workers
as a side project this one is for work
okay cool so Nikki saying that the if we
try to get some data with a graph QL
query and that data doesn't exist it'll
just return null for that piece of data
it it won't throw an error unless we
mark a field as required
so that's that's very good to know but
what we'll have to do is account for
that in our in our react component so
we'll need to set up a check for
instance with image to say if image is
not equal to null then try to render
this you know otherwise don't don't
render it because then we could actually
end up getting an error even if we don't
get it from graph QL will get it here in
in our component so I in that head
intended to put checks like that in but
for the sake of time I thought oh we'll
leave that off and if we get an error at
that point it would kind of almost be
like it better for a better teaching
moment to say okay let's fix this error
on the MGP says i'm a beginner and
trying to follow alright awesome yeah
definitely ask ask you some any
questions as you need to I'll do always
try to do my best to explain things but
I'm sure you you have other questions
what I just explained about handling no
values you all just are talking about in
the chats who you all know I don't have
to tell you you all know how to how we
handle that
okay Nikki's saying that we could be
used array dot fine that's yeah you know
what I don't use dot fine often so I
didn't even cross my mind but that's a
good idea I mean so instead of doing the
filter I'm interested would there be any
performance benefits to using fine
instead of filter if so you know I could
definitely switch that up if not then I
may just end up leaving it as filter
because that works if I see that Nikki
said you need to pass a callback
function and then do the Equality check
and he Nikki said that way earlier than
I figured it out so here so thanks Nikki
sorry I didn't look over in the chat the
chat was pretty pretty busy today so it
was it was tough for me to try to keep
up when I was was coding
I see a lot of you noticed my double
equal sign in the arrow function which
of course doesn't work thank you for
letting me know
Phoenix said wouldn't be better if the
image is in the center yeah I I just
kind of wanted to get the image on the
page there but you're right there
there's definitely some some styling
that could could happen there that would
make it look better
michael says can can you set up a
constant base URL and then append a file
name to it well yeah that's what I'd
like to do the problem with the URL is
just that it's not so this part of it
would remain the same no matter what for
all across the board for everything that
ever gets uploaded but this part here
this 2018 and then oh six these are the
folders and it's based on the year and
the month that that particular piece of
content was actually uploaded so these
will change so I need some way to get
these values so right now these values
aren't here they're only on this source
URL so that's why I need some way to
just get this and if I just get that
then of course I would have it and I
could just you know prepend it to the
source URL down here and everything
should should work out so that's the
thing so I'm thinking regular expression
might be the way to go here to pull this
this piece but I'm not sure
michael says i know it's a design
question but i'm wondering why the CV
link needs to be in a prominent position
it's like putting an employee's resume
at the top of their companies linked
yeah you know what you're right I the CV
in the current website is towards the
top but you're right it doesn't need to
be and we just left it there because we
pulled in the mark-up as is but maybe it
would be better at the bottom you know
maybe we the first thing maybe we don't
want to show users a link to download a
PDF right away actually I kind of like
that idea put it at the bottom is I'm a
big proponent of of not using PDFs
online if you can avoid it because you
know if you'd make that HTML instead of
in a PDF it would be I don't know how
screen readers handle PDFs but I know
they can handle HTML should be better
for that it would also be better for
search engine optimization for searching
so you know whatever's in that PDF is
not going to show up in our search on
the site it's not gonna show up in a
Google search right Google search does
not actually scan through PDFs
unless they've started doing that now I
don't know about it right so that
content is essentially locked away so if
we can avoid using the PDF completely
I'd be ok with that
but if we can't avoid it putting it down
the bottom I guess we'd be ok and it's
just a neat it's a better user
experience to be able to just go right
to the page and get the info I can't
stand especially when I'm on my phone I
go to somebody's website usually like a
restaurant website and I go to the menu
page and it doesn't tell me the menu
it just says here's a PDF then I have to
download the PDF on my phone open it up
and read it I may not even go to the
restaurant I'm just trying to see what
they have
and then I've got this restaurants PDF
on my phone until one day when I finally
decided to go into my downloads folder
and clean it out anyway alright sorry
about my PDF rant let's go back to the
less
world says what's the benefit of using
server-side rendering like next J s
Nietzsche says SEO and performance or
search engine optimization and
performance yeah for sure
that's I mean that that's the answer I
don't there may be some other benefit
but those to me are always the big two
okay Nicki says find has better
performance than filter so filter loops
over everything in the array fine stops
after it finds a match all right okay
that's definitely cool what time I'm
crossing over into the other ones I just
want to see really quick wood I don't
know what the syntax is for fun can I
just replace fine with with this
it's worth a shot and I can't I can't do
it
I'll switch it back for now and then
I'll just look up fine on mdn I didn't
think it would work but stuff like
that's always worth a shot because if it
works it saves you a lot of times
Nikki says for this use case the
performance difference would be
extremely small though just training
that es6 array methods muscle yeah
you're right I mean it's it's cool if I
get in there and it works then great but
it's not it's probably not gonna make a
difference a noticeable difference but
it'd be good to use the the better of
the two Christian browsers why not embed
the PDF and have it like an accordion
yeah is there some type of I'm assuming
there's some type of a react plug-in
that can easily help us embed a PDF I'd
be open to that we do it elsewhere on
the site for other types of content so
we use this service to do it though
called Cala mayo but if there was
something in react that would work I'd
be open to that still not quite as good
as the HTML is doing in HTML but it's
it's better than having to download the
PDF
alright Michael crow said so everything
before the last slash yeah for sure
that's exactly right so we just need
yeah everything before the last slash we
need to save that and use that as the
base URL okay Nikki says you wouldn't
need the additional map since fine we'll
return that element not an array oh okay
cool so that'll actually clean things up
quite a bit so I'm definitely gonna try
to use fine because it's gonna have the
added advantage of cleaning that up
because it looks a mess right now all
right Michael Carroll says screen
readers don't handle PDFs at all okay
that's good to know
and you know what if if I can try to
push to have the professors put that
content from the PDF into their profiles
instead I can use that as a really good
reason for screen readers right I mean
who's gonna argue against trying to make
things accessible are you going to look
like a terrible person if you don't care
about you know people who are blind or
vision-impaired
not being able to have your content so
that's that's an automatic loss of the
argument right
the world says the menu PDF classic lol
yeah I mean there are a lot of
restaurant websites that are so so
terrible especially when I travel I look
up restaurants more often than I do when
I'm at home and sometimes I just want to
say like I'm just gonna go this
restaurant and say like do you want me
to make you a website right like I but
then I I talked myself out of that
because that would be a terrible idea
I'd be doing these tiny websites for
restaurants and probably not making that
much money it would just be a big hassle
but I I just they're so bad I just want
to do it sometimes
okay cool so Nikki's giving me some code
here we may as well do it right now this
would be pretty simple so let's replace
all these filters with fine and then
inside the find I guess that would work
but then we don't need map anymore so
let's get rid of this
whoa second
area
so why is this not working
all right cool let's see if I did that
right this time definitely cut this down
a bit so I really like that
cool it works and we can we can verify
that actually yep it works so we have
these here awesome
Nikki thank you for that I like that
that's a lot cleaner
yeah michael says Christopher brown do
you work for Adobe so Christopher's
keeps on talking about the the PDF so
let's see Chris is said about start
going to Boise code works because I
couldn't get anyone to hire me having
just done free code camp and a pro bono
site for my school all right cool um
yeah good luck with with your learning
and with your job search
all right cool got through everything in
the live shot if I miss your question
I'm really sorry please put it in the
comments below this video or DM me on
some social media platform thank you for
all the help
definitely it was very helpful a lot of
the suggestions that you had and I'll
probably I don't know if I'll finish
this component on tomorrow stream or if
I'll finish it up myself off stream
we'll see but we'll probably still be
working in react tomorrow probably
stream again around the same time as we
did today so thanks again for everything
and thank you for watching I'll see
y'all tomorrow and until then have a
great day
I got signed out of YouTube somehow and
so the stream keeps going alright
alright how did this happen
all right now I'm gonna stop streaming
for real see who works this time